To be CS:GO’d is to be rekt, to be wronged,
to be utterly destroyed,
through no fault of your own, by the one they call Valve.
Now the traditional definition of getting CS:GO’d
involves putting your crosshair over somebody’s
head, pulling the trigger, and having the
bullets go through them like nothing happened.
But for the purposes of this video, we’ve
expanded the definition to include those pesky
bugs, those glitches, and the general what-the-f--kery
that has happened in pro play.
So let’s get it started with the traditional
definition of getting CS:GO’d.
(Casting)
Now, while getting CS:GO’d can really make
your blood boil, arguably worse are the random
seemingly unpredictable bugs that can cost you
your life, the round, and even the game.
(Casting)
Now, to round this one out guys, we wanted to look at some of the more lighthearted glitches in the game of CS:GO.
This kind of stuff you can’t even be mad at, you just have to sit back and laugh.
(Casting)
"It's just a flesh wound."
Well guys, that’s all we’ve got for you this week on Best of.
Now, this particular installment is really near and dear to my heart, because I’m always getting CS:GO’d in my games.
Nobody in the office even believes me. But you guys do, right???
Let me know in the comments and I will see you next week.